Speaker 1: You know, there's this theme that we've
been following in the Republican Party over the
last many years. Allegations are confessions.
Now, of course, we're not literally saying it.
It's not strictly true. But many of the things
that Republicans accused the left of doing,
we later find out they themselves are actually
doing. And one of those things is that a Trump
endorsed Republican has been caught tampering
with voting machines despite being a big.
One of the people crying wolf when it comes
to voter fraud. Reuters reports. Trump backed
Michigan Attorney General Candidate Involved
in voting system breach. Documents show this is
about the Republican nominee for Michigan attorney
general. His name is Matthew Perna. He led a team
that gained unauthorized access to voting machines
while hunting for evidence to support Trump's
claims about election fraud. Understand that in
searching for evidence of election fraud, you end
up tampering with voting machines and accessing
things that you're not supposed to. The analysis
shows that people working with Matthew to Paterno
examined a vote tabulator from Richfield Township,
a conservative stronghold of 3600 people in
Michigan. The Richfield security breach is one of
four similar incidents being investigated by the
current AG Democrat Dana Nessel. Under state law,
it is a felony to seek or provide an unauthorized
access to voting equipment. DePinho did not
respond to a request for comment. The involvement
of a Republican attorney general nominee in
a voting system breach comes amid a national
effort by backers of Trump's fraud falsehoods
to win state offices that could prove critical in
deciding any future contested election. Understand
what this is. Okay. Matthew Paterno is running
for attorney general. Were he to win that race,
he would be involved, generally speaking, in
supervising future elections in Michigan and
at least theoretically, in prosecuting real
instances of voter fraud, election tampering,
etc.. And he himself now has been allegedly
caught tampering with voting machines and
accessing things he is not supposed to have access
to. And all of it was done because he's looking
for voter fraud that actually doesn't exist. Here
is a clip of Donald Trump a few months ago, very
strongly praising Matt de Paterno. Check this out.
Speaker 3: Somebody said, well, he's very tough.
That's what you need. But he's putting his life
and reputation on the line right back to Paterno
after the 2020 election. Matt led the explosive
investigation to what happened in Antrim County,
where, among other irregularities, votes were
switched by mistake and that had to be corrected.
Speaker 1: None of it happened. Okay. So anyway,
the guy Trump really likes to investigate,
all of the fraud done against Trump is now
accused of tampering with voting machines. You
really can't script this stuff. You truly cannot.
Let's hope this guy doesn't win, because if he
does, then the temperature will be in charge
of prosecuting the voter fraud that may or may
not take place. That doesn't sound very good.